[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author rachel
shabby and the leader writer for the
daily telegraph tim stanley so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
the sunday times reveals the end of free
lateral flow tests as boris johnson is
set to announce a strategy of living
with covid within weeks
the observer quotes a former head of the
uk vaccine task force who believes that
once the booster campaign is over mass
jabs for covid should end and the virus
should be treated as an endemic similar
to the flu
scotland's sunday mail reports that in
an attempt to lessen pressure on the nhs
the government there is considering
paying people who care for their elderly
relatives as much as 15 pounds an hour
the foreign secretary liz truss writes
for the sunday telegraph insisting that
if an agreement can't be reached with
the eu
she'll invoke article 16 of the
post-brexit northern ireland protocols
with a review to resolving the matter
sensitively
according to the sunday express the home
secretary priti patel is calling on the
house of lords not to suffer new police
powers which she believes would give
greater comfort to the families of knife
crime victims
the sunday mirror here's danny dyer will
soon leave his longtime role on
eastenders
and the star has a story concerning the
celebrity spoon bender yuri gela
intriguing and uh we're joined tonight
by rachel shabby and tim stanley welcome
to you both let's start with the times
and that story that we mentioned at the
beginning of the papers run through
potential end-to-free lateral flow tests
uh something that the government
according to the article might be be
looking at him
this feels like a significant moment in
the pandemic
it's
it represents the government shifting
gears
from treating this uh as as a pandemic
that you throw everything at
back to acting as though it's endemic
it's a dreadful disease it's one you
want to
limit people's exposure to but
essentially people have got to get on
with living and they've got to they've
got to live around the disease and treat
it more like seasonal flu
that kind of action seems to be
supported by the relatively mild nature
of omicron though having said that of
course there's still a lot of pressure
on hospitals the times also quotes nadim
zahawi the education secretary saying
that he would like to see the number of
days spent in isolation cut from seven
to five this is also significant
why because again it feeds into the
change in the nature of the problem we
face
this time last year
the the central problem with covid was
that it was a horrible disease that was
putting people into intensive care
it's still doing that
but the bigger problem
with the nhs isn't so much the direct
consequence of the disease of what it
does to the patient
as it is the number of staff having to
take time off and i know there are other
issues like underfunding which i'm sure
we can get into but
that is the central problem is people
actually taking time off work because
they've got the disease so what so how
we saying that we need to cut the number
of days in isolation from seven to five
gives us some hint of what really is of
the change in the nature of the concern
with the government and the change in
its focus away from stopping the
transmission of the disease
and towards instead persuading the
public to come to terms with the disease
and to live yes sir and it's creating a
senior white horse source saying i don't
think we're in a world where we can
continue to hand out free lateral flow
tests to everybody it's likely we will
move to a scenario where there is less
testing but we have a capacity to ramp
it up if necessary and according to the
article it's worth saying that um what
what they're saying here is the new
system could mean free tests being
provided only to um high risk settings
such as care homes hospitals uh and
schools rachel
yes this is um this is an announcement
coming from the government on the very
same day that uh we the uk have now
passed a hundred and fifty thousand
uh deaths from covid uh which i know
that you know sky has been reporting on
throughout the day and obviously um
you know my heart goes out to anyone
who's lost a loved one
because of this terrible disease and
when you hear people who have lost loved
ones talk one of the things they say is
that they don't wish this upon anyone
else and of course none of us do
so with that in mind what actually is
the government doing with this
it's not going to
help us live with covid
if it starts to
make um charge people for lateral flow
tests all that will do
is mean that the
disparities the economic disparities
that
along along which the disease has
ravaged this country will be exacerbated
because people who can't afford to buy a
test won't buy a test so that let's be
clear that that's what this policy will
do
it will just mean that people can't
afford to have tests and let's bear in
mind that in the last few weeks this has
been the way that people have been able
to
um you know live
with the virus if indeed that you know
if that's the government's stated
objective you know people have been able
to have lateral flow tests before they
go out before they meet loved ones
um
you know before kids go to school there
are so many contexts in which having
regular free lateral toe flow tests is
vital is actually vital to allowing us
to get on with our lives so
this announcement is just baffling it
just seems so wrong-headed and so
short-sighted
it's obviously going to cost far far
more in the long term i just want to to
read you a government response to that
story that we've just got in saying that
everyone can continue to get free tests
and we are continuing to encourage
people to use rapid tests when they need
them record numbers of tests are being
delivered to pharmacies homes and those
who need them the uk's testing program
is the biggest in europe with over 400
million pcr and lfd tests carried out
since the start of the pandemic testing
continues to play an important role in
helping people live their day-to-day
lives keep businesses running and keep
young people in school so although the
the article um
is suggesting that uh there will be an
end to to free test it by no means as
something that's been decided as of now
tim
no no that's correct
and also just to pick up what rachel
just said about the costs i think that's
a very good point over the course of the
christmas holiday i probably took
between 10 or 12 of these tests in order
to make sure that i could safely go and
see people and i could safely go to work
so it started to become factored into
people's behavior this the free lateral
tests
are a way that many people have found a
way of living with the virus
and if you if you then have to char if
you then charge for them then obviously
people are going to make different
different kind of decision but that
leads us on to a subtle psychological
change in the british people's attitudes
towards coving if the test
in the future is no longer free the
implication is that the government
doesn't think covert is that greater
risk for that greater number of people
that it doesn't have to give them free
testing to ensure that they can safely
get they can safely go around without
transmitting it to everyone which leads
us on to the story i believe on the
front cover of the guardian
uh which quotes the former head of the
the vaccine task force doctor clive
dicks
saying
the observer
the observer my apologies we need to
stop uh we need to stop uh
this cycle of vaccine a vaccination
programs
and that we need to come to terms with
the disease uh treat it like we would
other ones and not constantly be
vaccinating people against it again this
is about setting the british people up
with coming to terms with life in a
world in which covid is one of a number
of diseases which threatens us
and in which by the way
the problems that we face in tackling it
return us to long-term issues about
underfunding in the nhs and the number
of doctors because that that's the
that's the structural reason right now
why we're struggling with this but with
this omicron wave its absence is at work
but it's also a consequence of 10 years
or so of underfunding and of a decline
in the number of doctors per per patient
and a comparatively low number of
intensive uh intensive care beds
compared to many countries on the
continent so
it's all this is pointing us towards the
beginning of a cult a change in cultural
attitudes towards code
and rachel the article quoting a doctor
clive dick saying that uh we need to
return to a new normality and
eventually covet is going to have to be
treated like the flu
well you know what i think that probably
sounds right about you know jab number
four
um i do think that in a global sense it
makes no sense whatsoever
for some countries to race ahead with
boosters while other countries in the
world still don't even have access to
vaccine one
and in terms of producing more variants
globally
that's creating more likelihood of that
i would like to say one thing about
omicron is that it's slightly deceptive
i believe in that
it it is um the research is showing that
it is milder and it's not affecting
lungs in the same way however
it is so much more transmissible that
you end up with
um just as many people hospitalized
because the infection rates are so much
higher so actually there are
hospitals
across england outside of london where
they are
seeing um numbers of patients in with
covid at similar numbers to the peak of
january 21 and bear in mind that we
haven't reached our peak yet we're
probably 10 days or two weeks away from
that so i don't think we're at that
stage yet
where it's not
um
you know a very serious and
life-threatening disease that it
obviously we are heading in that
direction but i don't think we're there
yet and we also need to decide whether
we're happy for uh for the nhs to live
with that situation with 25 nhs trusts
declaring um an emergency a critical
incident with you know staff falling out
of the nhs last year apparently recorded
record numbers um
left
the nhs
is it acceptable to put nhs and other
health workers under this level of
stress and trauma um i don't think we
should be living with that
rachel we have no choice
we have no choice and this is why the
government's exploring this calculation
about the number of days that people
take off uh in isolation um accepting
that argument which is entirely true
that's an absurd thing to say we do have
a choice
well what else we supposed to do in the
next month or so to fix that problem
other than making sure that more nhs
staff can go back to work we're not
going to transform the nhs in the next
month we just have to get over this hump
and that's why i'm saying the government
is exploring this calculation
people are in isolation so the staff can
go back to work you're right to say um
first of all you were right to identify
ten years of conservative government
under funding of the nhs is leading us
to this problem but one of the first
things the government could do right now
is make sure that all nhs staff have
adequate ppe at the moment they're not
they're not given even um properly
ventilating masks or properly filtrating
masks so even something like that would
make a huge difference the government
just isn't interested
thank you both we are going to take a
break don't worry we're coming back tim
thanks very much for the moment coming
up
number 10 offers no comment as the prime
minister is once again accused of
attending a social gathering during the
first lockdown we'll discuss that next
[Music]
you're watching the press preview still
with me rachel shabby and tim stanley
there they are welcome back now i have
to say i've been educated by this uh
next um item in the sunday times a story
involving the prime minister and uh a
biob which i had no idea what that stood
for rachel educate us all and uh tell us
about the story
i feel like it's almost like showing
your age when you know what
you'll mean
to a party or indeed a restaurant where
you're allowed to bring your own bottle
of alcohol
but in this case it's an invite to a
party at downing street um
which
um
some 40 people were thought to have
attended including
it transpires boris johnson um so he
didn't join other christmas parties that
were organized uh this is looking at um
2020 and this party was believed to have
been held on may
the 20th um but he is according to this
report in the times thought to have been
at this one um of course
downing street denies pretty much
everything about this story yes and this
at a time when restrictions were in
place and this is the the allegation i
think laid by dominic cummings that this
is five days after the the pictures of
that first um well downing street say
working meeting that we saw people in
the the back garden of downing street
but this is another party which
invitations were sent out on may the
20th happened on may the 20th tim
that's correct i'd love to attend more
work meetings where you're invited to
bring your own
it's always seemed to me that uh if you
vote brexit you turn into the french um
that seems like a very continental way
of doing work but it it it feels uh it's
very embarrassing um and
obviously it taps into the wider
questions around the wallpapering and
redecorating of the prime minister's
flat which just just means the prime
minister begins the year uh still
fending off allegations uh the
interesting question one interesting
question about some of the stuff related
uh to socializing at uh downing street
is where all this stuff is coming from
who is leaking it whose interest is it
to do it who produced that photograph
no one's quite sure but still the
stories are coming yes interesting and
that email is going to be key evidence
in a sleazy inquiry being run by
whitehall enforcer sue gray thank you
very much both for the moment